what's going on how do we get can we get
in the door you have to kick him inside
door I don't we don't care I don't care
my parents are here I can't have I just
love this camera he used to live here so
he can tap into anything but we have
cameras up for other reasons I got you
you know he's in there for a fact I know
for a
fact we kick your swear to God go ahead
please this girl I don't know what's
wrong with this girl oh there's a girl
in there with him yes I told them this
only I told them this there's a girl in
there she's very SL and slim my husband
said he didn't really get over the look
at her but he's yelling at
her that's right follow you her faces
she can't see out of her eyes Okay so
this is why I'm nervous this is why I've
been calling his officer all morning and
I don't even know if that's even you
100% you know 100%
100%
Joe said Joe said he might have
something he's got something with a flat
head that might be able to pound it up I
but there's not it's
like unless this top on the whole thing
maybe they just sheared the the flat
part off so
it like it so we're
a Joe's got a pry
bar
work yeah on BWC
yeah I say we're going through the roof
through the top up
Shing
somewhere all kind of Easter
eggs right doesn't look like it actually
has I know that's I'm saying like a full
head on both sides it doesn't look like
it's just a
pen this one
just two smaller
P I'm more used to the
one on the
bottom one half Jerry you doing getting
that bar
we can go through the roofcraft oh shit
that thing's sweet that's your personal
yeah What scenario did you see that you
might need
that it's weird you've been on 20 how
many years you haven't used it
yet it's weird last day that's a going
out let moss do it since he's done yeah
go Moss is the one that should have go
up on a roof moss and
your
way yeah they left the key in and once
he got in he a push or a pull pull out
looks hes are on the outside but they
look like get that if we put that bar on
that where the dead bolt is and just
push the frame a little bit that frame
will Flex
enough
wait I gave it to you the one time what
did we use it on that window where dude
died in the house oh
yeah surprise I don't know how sharp the
blade is 43 would probably be like to be
present for this so that way yes lck he
can have this welcome to day shift C
here go who's in 22 no 43 Davis that way
uh
Li I can't even speak now a
stroke you got a little hammer in on
that you know is this Nicki's first day
first day I saw him I walked in there
perfect let's go realiz
that yeah we were like got time he's
like oh I didn't see him in the book I'm
like
okay then you you're stuck in the
elevator we're
like you started like half 30 seconds
too
early well I brought my truck today cuz
caren's got jeury Duty and I am like
panicking driving in up Mor that cuz
it's like this high from everything like
this close and it's tapping off
everything and so I was driving slow and
I couldn't really find a spot for Park I
saw where he parked I'm like when I when
I first start parking I thought the same
thing I'll just pull in park and get out
and go I didn't want to drive around I
made the mistake of going around think I
can park in the
back so you got out and checked
everything like okay's
here a
lot first you got like 12 us
here here's our option we got to there
by now well we were thinking the roof go
through the
roof might need
that we're thinking we're thinking a
spud bar will take
it we gave multiple announcements we'll
do announce again here William Stack
from Police Department this is your last
chance come out now with your hands up
or we'll be sending the K9 in to
apprehend you you will get bit by the
dog William last
[Applause]
chance please better come out come out
now your hands
up
no will you come out now ha
police
lot come out come out come out now
nothing in your hands nothing in your
hands
now
buddy okay coming out or can you see him
get out here now come out now come out
now bro you're going to get fucked up in
a second you better come right the fuck
out now
now keep everything out of your hands
he's in the Attic he's in the coming
keep everything out of your
hands keep your hands
up keep your hands
up we'll go hands down put it down drop
it drop no not your whole body get up
turn around and walk
backwards walk towards us keep your
hands
up that way just keep coming watch your
step right there you get
that come on out
here
come else come out the after you come
out you're not going to get your black
socks in the
countway socks are
fucking's he's excited good boy can't
hear you good
[Applause]
boy okay what do you need to get
down let me get this ladder
okay can you reach it hey one second
dude hold up let me move these rooms
no all right can you that you see where
this
is you want to wait a get it
closer
no here just kick this out of way I'm
going to move
this we
can
there's some green boots up there bring
no fuck them no fuck them you don't need
no
boots big man can fucking walk
himself no one else up
there where do you live at dear
th Thompson
how far away is
that 30 minutes like close to Shan why
don't you have a sit right see right
there why don't you have a sit right see
right there
on probably where she at yeah why don't
you just sit down
there guys
water we'll get you some stuff
here
is there any weapons up there here is
there any weapons or anything up there
no there's no apartment number just says
on the third floor male and female
throwing things out of the
apartment what's that
you
okay uh what's your soci security number
number Ro sweet
2677 you would be kicking through all
this
top
just a piece of paper it's support paper
but still I mean we all know what goes
up in fold the piece of papers all
right my dude
step on up
there yes
sir hold on
[Applause]
minut does that look like one on
there she any lature marks
I'm sure she'll be willing to tell us
the whole story I didn't bar ask her
about other injuries and she said
something much she didn't want to P her
pant